From the perspective of the startup,
I was always kind of skeptical of raising money.
It feels like people do it too quickly, too easily. Um,
but I don't know what the hell I'm talking about it.
One is the one should a startup raise money.
And from the perspective of the investor,
when should the investor invest in a startup? Like,
is there a timing thing here? Is there, um, what, yeah.
It's, it's a, it's a,
it's a very important question because the venture capital community is
only going to fund, you know, sub 1% of enterprise to start it in the,
in the United States every year. Like maybe 10 basis points of them,
like one in a thousand. And the reason is it's jet fuel.
You only want to take that money if you really want to build something big and
you want to build it fast. And when you put jet fuel behind a startup,
as we've seen with other rockets, things can blow up and people can die.
You know, it's not people literally dying, but the business can go up in smoke,
right? Like rockets get blown up all the time.
That's pays X as part of their ambitious plans and startups seven out of 10
startups. We invest in go to zero. Now,
if you were to start the business and only build it off customer revenue and use
your own money and go nice and slow and grow 10% a year,
the chances of you blowing up the rocket are very low because you're riding a
bicycle. You can go a little faster, but the bicycle can only go so fast.
And once you start taking that money, the way the portfolio,
the way venture capital is constructed as a, um,
in the mix of like MIT or Harvard's endowments is, you know,
we're gonna put some money into a safe things.
And then we're going to have these really binary things over here.
And they probably put 5% in venture capital. Traditionally,
it's grown to 20% just as a function of how successful it's been. So, you know,
the Harvard's of the world and MIT is probably one, five or 10% in venture,
but it's grown to 25% because you know,
companies like Airbnb and Uber have grown so big and Tesla,
but the goal is in these venture funds,
we're going to invest in 30 names and one or two of them are going to return
three times the capital we've deployed.
So it's a $300 million fund and there's 30 names. They each got 10 million.
That means one of the 10 million is going to return the fund plus.
So that means it has to grow 30 X and then 60 X to
double the fund.
And you're really supposed to be doing three times cash on cash.
So that $300 million funds,
the expectation is in 10 years to return 900 billion triple the person's money,
as opposed to the stock market, which doubles your money in the same period.
So you're supposed to do 25% annualized returns in order to
triple the money.
And maybe I have an outlying chance of four or five times the money,
which does happen sometimes when you have an outlier on your portfolio like Uber
or Facebook was.
And what that means is the venture capitalist's behavior.
And the game they're playing is different than you. As the founder, you,
as the founder,
you may really care about this and it dying really matters to you.
And then you've got a venture capitalist. Who's like, we're betting on 30 names.
We need two of them to hit it out of the park,
maybe three and nothing else is meaningful.
So now you start thinking about the game theory there you're dealing with,
you know,
money that is coming in that only cares about you going a
hundred X. Yes, it's a whole different ball game.
Whereas if you build off revenue, you don't have to do that.
And if you look@acompanylikecalm.com, we invested at 5 million.
The next round they did was two 50.
They were so capital efficient that they grew from $10,000 a month in revenue to
millions of dollars a month in revenue over those four years,
since we invested and they didn't raise money in between, well,
it was unbelievable. And I've only seen this happen three or four times.
And all this capital efficient meaning, uh,
based on customer revenue alone,
plus some small amount of fundraising you're able to go, like,
how hard is it to do that?
It takes extreme product market fit.
You have to have a great price for your product that has a great margin. Um,
yeah. And if you're doing something in hardware, it's probably impossible.
Cause it's super capital intensive.
So it's probably gotta be a software business, software, hardware,
businesses take a lot more.
Venture capitals, get in the way at all the business or do,
or is it possible to get out of the way?
Yeah. If you,
if you get young venture capitalists who are starting their career,
they're very nervous and scared because they're putting all these bets and then
there's a very weird thing that happens. The bad news comes first.
So companies that don't work out, go out of business immediately. Yes.
So if it's not going to be calm or Robin hood or Uber, those take seven,
you know, you have, uh, one of those great successes somewhere in your five,
six, seven, eight as an investor. What is the first five years?
Like the first five years?
You feel like an idiot because you let's say you make these, uh, 10 bets
in year two,
two or three of them come back and they don't have product market fit and
they're out of money and they say, can we have more money? And you say, no,
we have to go get it from somebody else because you have to prove that there's
still a market for it. We may keep our prorata.
We may put a little bit into maintain our percentage ownership,
but we're not going to give you another big chunk of money.
And that company dies. So now you've got 10 million up in smoke, boom,
10 million up smoke.
So this is called the J curve where your performance goes down.
And then it's only in years, four or five and six, it starts going up.
And what you're seeing right now is the people who started like I did in 2011,
12 years ago, in 2009, I started investing. We all look like geniuses,
why we're at the end of the cycle.
We invested after when the stock market was on the floor after the financial
crisis. And it's gone straight up since. So everybody looked,
there's a couple little blips in there, but generally speaking there,
hasn't been like a major crash, uh, with the exception of the pandemic crash,
but that bounced back. And so, you know,
it takes a decade to figure out if you're good at it.
And then if the market crashes again,
everybody feels like an again and the cycle starts again.
So you are now as a founder,
you are now inserting yourself into that casino.
And now you've got all these other forces pushing and pulling and you're
growing. Let's say your company was growing 50%. You feel like, wow,
I'm successful. I made a million dollars last year.
Now I'm doing a million and a half. And,
and the first thing a VC is going to you is how do we triple we're moving.
We're growing too slow too. But that's like you said, that beautifully, uh,
is a rocket fuel. It's, uh, in, in the sense it's a kind of motivation.
It's a dry, I mean, it's a positive if you want that, if you want that,
if you want that, if you want to go to Navy seal school,
you are going to be in pain.
And they're going to put that hose in your face while you're underwater with
your hands tied behind your back in the pool and you're to be choking and you
might have to do CPR on you. And like every couple of years, tragically,
somebody dies in Navy seal school. Well,
it doesn't mean we're getting rid of the Navy seals groggy. If he does, he does.